well unless you have completely checked
out over the last three days as I did
you certainly have heard by now that
Donald Trump claims he will be arrested
tomorrow there has never been an arrest
or indictment of a sitting or former
president in the United States if Trump
is right if he's telling the truth slash
correctly informed which is still a
question mark this will be one of the
biggest news stories in decades in the
United States and the world quite
frankly as the globe waits to see Will
trump be even potentially held
accountable for any of the Myriad things
that he did while he was president and
in the lead-up during the 2016 campaign
where do we even start well let's start
with how this all started with Donald
Trump's outrageous all caps posts
riddled with grammatical and spelling
errors to his social media platform
truth social
you'll call it whatever the hell you
want look at the news and and it is news
quite frankly that Donald Trump
predicted his arrest on that platform
let's go right into it and again if
you're not if you're listening
these are these messages are in all
capital letters which I think is just
another one of these little details
let's get right into it quote our nation
is now third world and dying the
American dream is dead the radical left
anarchists have stolen our presidential
election and with it the heart of our
our country I'm reading it as written
Trump writing Stalin of course a famous
German Christmas bread riddled with nuts
spices as well as candied or dried fruit
the anarchists have Stalin our
presidential election and with it the
heart of our our country American
Patriots are being arrested and held in
captivity like animals while criminals
and leftist thugs are allowed to roam
the streets that's not true
killing and burning with no retribution
that's a lie millions are flooding
through our open borders and the wrong
borders spelling borders like if you
were a border at a boarding house many
from prisons and mental institutions
that is also a lie the crime and
inflation are destroying our very way of
life now illegal leaks from a corrupt
and highly political Manhattan District
Attorney's office which has allowed new
records to be set in violent crime well
the violent crime rate is higher in
Oklahoma City
than it is in New York City but why let
the facts get in the way of a good all
caps ramp Trump continuing and whose
leader is funded by George Soros
indicate that with no crime being able
to be proven and based on an old and
fully debunked by numerous other
prosecutors fairy tale the Far and Away
leading Republican candidate and former
president of the United States of
America will be arrested on Tuesday of
next week I know that that's an
incoherent word salad but Trump is
saying they're going to arrest him
tomorrow
protest take our nation back Trump
demands and then continuing the calls
for protest and what is increasingly
concerningly going to be a violent
protest which we know Trump supporters
are capable of remember January 6th
Trump posting more quote it's time we
are a nation in steep decline being led
into World War III by a crooked
politician who doesn't even know he's
alive but who is surrounded by evil and
Sinister people who based on their
actions on defunding the police there
has been no defunding destroying our
military the military is fine open
borders the borders are not open and no
voter ID well voter ID depends on each
state inflation which is down raising
taxes Biden hasn't done that and much
more can only hate our now failing USA
we just can't allow this anymore they're
killing our nation as we sit back and
watch we must save America protest
protest protest and then finally
continuing this morning with these all
caps tirades quote the lead prosecutor
for the corrupt Manhattan DA's office
worked as a lawyer for crooked Hillary
Clinton and her Law Firm left this
Democrat firm with others to volunteer
to quote get Donald Trump at the DA's
office for free
he quit in a huff when D.A Bragg said
there was no case here he then
unethically and illegally wrote and
published a book about the case while it
was going on this is unheard of stuff
the case is now completely compromised
and reports are that Mark pomerance is
in trouble this is all wild stuff so let
me break it down for you in in with
clear terms
no president has ever been arrested nor
indicted Trump claims he will become the
first tomorrow there have been two
American Presidents subjected to
criminal investigations those were
Richard Nixon and yes Donald Trump Nixon
of course resigned from the presidency
before he could be impeached over the
Watergate scandal and that involved the
break-in at the Democratic National
Committee headquarters and the attempts
of course to cover it up Nixon was never
indicted
and uh Trump may be indicted Trump could
also be wrong and Trump could also be
lying I believe that this if it happens
politically will make Trump stronger
except if there are more indictments I
don't believe this case which is about
Stormy Daniels is the strongest case
against Trump however it's possible as
we've said before that prosecutors are
saying to themselves I have a case
I have a case against Trump but I don't
want to be the first to indict not the
first to indict Trump the first to
indict any former president so we may
have at the federal level we may have in
Georgia we may have the Tisch James uh
investigation remember this is another
investigation they may be waiting for
another indictment first to then say now
I'm ready
I didn't have the testicular fortitude
ovarian fortitude whatever term you want
to use to be the first to indict Trump
but I am certainly willing to be second
or third and this may be
When the Levy Breaks for our Led
Zeppelin fans
um and in that case I think it will
weaken Trump if it just overwhelms him
with criminal cases however
I think if this is the only indictment
it will Galvanize Trump's supporters
and help him in his Republican primary
we will get to that later let's next
talk about how will Maga react if Donald
Trump is arrested
as many of my viewers and listeners of
course know I have many family members
who work in the field of mental health
and I think one of the most important
things that we can do is to both
increase access and reduce stigma when
it comes to Mental Health Services and
that's why I am thrilled that one of our
sponsors today is better help better
help is the world's largest therapy
service and it is 100 online with better
help you can tap into a network of over
25 000 licensed and experienced
therapists an important word therapists
who can help you with a wide range of
issues you answer a few questions about
your needs and your preferences and
better help will match you with a
therapist that meets your needs you can
then talk to your therapist however you
feel comfortable could be text could be
chat phone video call you can message
your therapist anytime you can schedule
live sessions when it's convenient and
if your therapist isn't the right fit
for any reason you can switch to a new
therapist at no additional charge with
better help you get the same
professionalism and quality you expect
from in-office therapy but it's on your
schedule
and it's at a more affordable price get
10 off your first month at
betterhelp.com Pacman the link is down
below